this is joint work with Cynthia Abreu be
friendly and the affiliations of you
might have noticed stuff color-coded
okay so so the main goal of the talk is
to give a very simple algorithm and
analysis for differentially private PCA
and let me start out by defining what I
mean by that so this is the problem I
want to look at I have a matrix a this
is a M by n matrix so think of it as M
vectors and M n dimensions so each
vector comes from an individual so the
first row could be Adams Netflix movie
probably we ratings the second row would
be Moretz and so on and since we believe
that people's preferences lines of low
dimensions I will define a low
dimensional subspace that contain all of
these vectors well I'll have some noise
so I won't get all of these vectors I
want to capture a lot of the variance oh
these vectors so I want to find a sub
space such that all of these vectors are
close to this this subspace and I guess
we know this is done by the PCA now one
one kind of nice thing about the PCA is
that it gives me optimality for all
possible pretty much any measure you can
think of you can think of the probing
Islam or the to norm and so on so that
makes it difficult to evaluate your
approximate mechanisms because you have
to pay Commission this talk will be
picking the measure which I find the
most natural which is the total amount
of variance that you will capture so I
have these vectors essentially there's a
projection of this vector x1 onto the
subspace that's how much I'm getting out
of x1 I'll take the squared projection
and I'll add that up over
all the vectors in all the rows of my
matrix so I want to find a projection so
that this quantity is as large as
possible just the sum of the projections
of the rows of the matrix lens quit and
actually if you stare at it it basically
has this nice matrix form that's not
really okay so I'll also be assuming and
can think of this as just a
normalization that all my vectors are
length one alright most one but so
that's the problem I have these vectors
of length at most one I want to find a
sub space in which all of them lie or
which contains as much of the variance
of these vectors as possible so as we
know this quantity is maximized by the
subspace spanned by the topcase right
singular vectors of a which are also the
top K eigen vectors of a transpose a so
this pi K is what we'll be trying to
approximate in this talk while
guaranteeing differential privacy so
obviously I won't define differential
privacy except to say that since the
model we are looking at is where each
person contributes a row to matrices are
neighboring if they differ in one room
so why do we want to do this I guess
this is a useful subroutine and many
algorithms if we think of her excise as
kind of data which lies in low
dimensional subspace plus noise you want
to eliminate noise to end up with a low
dimensional problem this could help you
both from a computational viewpoint from
a generalization error viewpoint also
from the privacy viewpoint and so on and
so forth and in fact this was the
subroutine that was used by make sure
you never know in their implementation
of a differentially private PCA
differential if I might recommendation
system for the Netflix challenge so yeah
ok so this is the problem we'll try to
solve in this model of privacy there has
been a fair bit of previous work so
starting with block McSherry anism they
showed that one simple way to design
good french private mechanism is to take
the covariance matrix nad appropriate
amount of noise to that matrix and then
work with that and since differential
privacy has the post processing property
anything I do to that is correct and
surprisingly this is actually a variant
essentially this is the algorithm we
will be talking about today I will give
a new much nicer and much better
analysis of this algorithm
so Frank McSherry
gets back in the day proposed using the
expression mechanism to solve this
problem and this was also used in works
by Chaudhary sir within Sinha and by
joint work with Michael capítulo and
myself and you can show that the
exponential mechanism gives you this
kind of guarantee so if I measure my
error in terms of the two norm
don't worry about what that is but
basically my additive error is something
like some polynomial in K and this is
probably not optimal
Tansen so there's a linear dependence on
it
and in fact there's a lower bound that
your case needed K there but so this is
essentially what we know about the pure
privacy case and this n is necessary and
sufficient for approximate differential
privacy you can get this down to
something like K square times square
root n using techniques from using the
work of heart and drop and I guess more
recent work of heart and Roth gets you
something like square root KN times some
term that depends on the eigenvalue
separation if you have some separation
of eigenvalues you can get something
like square root can also I mean it's
the same amount as above you just
because you're only talking about casing
the values can always assume a
separation of 1 over K so if you want to
make that a cake to the 1 point 5 or 7 I
mean if you want you can always make the
depends on K worth and isolate up the
gap but this is okay so as I said we'll
be using the homing and small measures
or rather the Frobenius norm squared
measure it's in addition to being nice
and intuitive it also has the advantage
that you get good guarantees for this
they also imply better guarantees for
the other measures okay and this is the
guarantee we get so the amount of
variance I capture is at most K to 10
more than the best possible if you
actually cared about the 2 norm or the
Frobenius norm you can get something
like for proving its normal square root
of that for two norm there is no
dependence on K it's just routine
and just for comparison the two non
mouth
so I guess previous works only here to
norm bound sand they all had a
dependence on K we get rid of dependence
on K and I think the more appealing
thing is it's both the algorithm and the
proof are very simple and I'll actually
hopefully show you both of them
ah so I'm hiding lots of content so it's
something like square root log 1 over
Delta divided by epsilon hidden in all
of these but yeah if you think of a
somewhat nicer notion of privacy like
likes like CDP then you can get rid of
the Logano data but don't worry about it
additionally if you have a separation of
eigenvalues you can actually improve
this box you can do even better you can
go below this and moreover we show a
lower bound showing that no
differentially private mechanism can do
better than this in general so k root n
is what's something very simple gives
and cannot be proved it
okay so here's a quick taco I'm playing
I'll first show you the mechanism I'll
give you a complete proof of the utility
gap utility for the gap independent case
we give you a roughs and hand move a
little for the gap independent case and
then talk about some of the results okay
so let me start with a few observations
as we said already the optimal subspace
is just the subsystem of spanned by the
top K eigen vectors of a transpose C a
transpose a is the covariance matrix
it's nothing but the sum of xixi
transpose summed over all the rows so if
I think of the matrix C as my object of
interest it's just the sum of individual
contributions so each person contributes
their xixi transpose and if I take out
Cynthia's data from this matrix the
matrix a prime that I get the
neighboring matrix the difference
between these two is exactly xixi
transpose where X is table corresponding
to Cynthia so the sensitivity of this
point this object C is essentially this
xixi transpose what do I know about X I
X I transpose I know that X I has norm
one and what that means is that X I X I
transpose is a rank one matrix whose
spectral norm is one so so that one
matrix only one eigenvalue that's one
what that means is that the Frobenius
norm of xixi transpose is at most one so
what have I said here if I look at this
quantity C by adding or removing one
person the total change in this matrix
the sum of squared entries of the change
is at most one so now instead of viewing
this
so so if I view this matrix as one wrong
vector and saying one person can change
the total l 2-norm
change this long vector by a total l2
amount of 1 which basically tells me
that I can use the Gaussian noise
mechanism so formally here's the
mechanism I have this matrix in row has
long one I'll compute the true
covariance matrix I'll define the error
matrix which is just essentially
constant in each entry and I just add
the two and now essentially the the
basic analysis of the Gaussian mechanism
going back to a long time ago tells me
that outputting C prime is
differentially private so I can output
the covariance matrix no you can do
whatever you want with it in particular
you can output the top K subspace of
this if you want so the privacy as I
said is immediate because this is row
being a small one gives us a vector it's
a norm one change so adding Gaussian
noise of amount one in each direction
gives me privacy so let me get to
utility before I get to that let me just
set up some notation I'll say PI K is
the Takia subspace of C so this is the
object I am really looking for this is
opt what this mechanism will output will
be PI K Twitter so that's the top a
subspace of C to D so the proof is as
big as the algorithm and I'll show you
the whole proof here linear algebra
proofs often get very hard to read
because of notation but bear with me
this is short and it's very simple so
the quantity I care about this is PI K
times a transpose Rho beam is norm
squared this is equal to the trace of
this times X transpose which is equal to
this quantity here
this is just restating now trace has the
nice property that it's linear so a
transpose a was C let me add and
subtract e to it and because race is
linear I can write it out as the
difference of this trace in this trace
so good so so far I've not done anything
that just reexpress my objective
function as the difference of two traces
but as we know any interesting proof
should have an inequality so we'll have
one what do I go about by kilted by K
twiddle this is the optimal subspace for
C plus C so in particular it's no better
than the then using PI K so if I had
instead use PI K I would be worse off
for C plus C so I have this inequality I
can replace by K by twiddle by PI K and
I'll get a greater than equal to here
and now I again use linearity of trace
the first term is what I care about and
I'm left with this this trace of the
difference of the subspaces times e as
my error so the total variance I capture
is at least the best possible - this
little irritable ok so now all I need to
do is understand this little error term
so firstly note that these are
projection matrices into rank K
subspaces so this is the rank to K
matrix taken some matrix projected it
down to two K dimensions
that's a rank to K matrix so this is at
most 2k times the 2 norm of this matrix
and standard results in random matrix
theory tell me that the 2 norm of a
random Gaussian matrix is square root of
M so that's it this gives me that
algorithm is at least opt minus K 10
square root to get M square
any questions
good so notice we didn't make any kept
assumptions towards the ROS question
there could be cases when you actually
what you are not putting if there's no
gap you may be outputting something
which is very different from the topic a
singular subspace but but we will still
capture as much variance as the best one
one interesting thing to notice is that
I am NOT averaging when I define like my
left hand side so this is increasing
linearly with them as you get more and
more entries in your matrix the total
variance in the subspace in any
probabilistic model is increasing
linearly with them my error is staying
independent of M and it's not hard once
you have this to get other variance for
the other notions of error let me not
get into that instead let me talk about
the utility how you prove any bound when
you have a gap okay
so recall what we proved in that big box
was that the algorithm gives me at least
opt minus this trace here so earlier we
just analyze this as saying this is a
rank a matrix this is a small spectral
matrix but but morally when your if your
matrix actually has a gap between the
cake and the k plus ones singular value
then it's not easy for a perturbation to
change by K so so we use that factor so
just just notice that this is still rank
to K matrix so I can actually bound this
error term by 2k times the 2 norm of
this matrix earlier we just found a the
to know by the norm of e but this
actually will be small when there is a
when I do have a gap so so if you can
actually control this quantity we will
actually get an improvement and we are
of course not the first ones to ask this
question this is an old question in
matrix perturbation theory and what's
known as the Davis Khan sine theta
theorem or variants of that basically
say that this error the difference
between pike and packet twiddle becomes
smaller as the gap between the cape and
the k plus 1 at eigenvalue increases
right up c plus C here but that can be
easily changed to C with an additive
square root of n this doesn't really
matter so much because when the gap is
less than square root n the previous
bound is actually that that so so this
nice sine theta theorem which actually
has a very simple proof if I had five
more minutes I would show you the proof
of that as well basically shows that you
get error which kind of decreases with
the gap in the eigenvalues one thing
that's kind of very interesting about
this algorithm is that if you think of a
probabilistic model where so each of
these x i's are coming from some
Redemption subspace plus noise the true
gap between Sigma K and Sigma k plus 1
is actually increasing linearly with
them as I have more and more samples the
covariance matrix is the unabridged
covariance matrix is increasing linearly
with them so my gap is actually
decreasing with them my error is
actually decreasing with them even if
even though the quantity I'm
approximating is increasing with so I'm
getting really really fast convergence
additionally if you don't actually have
a gap between the gate on the K+ wanna
you're willing to put a K prime
dimensional subspace you can get bounce
where this gets replaced by K prime plus
1 so we can also get subspace
convergence guarantees using these
arguments so by K in fact is converges
to PI K hat sorry I get really converges
to PI K yeah okay
so that's all I'm gonna say about the
mechanism in the proof let me spend a
little bit of time on some of the other
results that we can prove using this
simple approach so the first one is the
is an application to online prediction
so consider the following model where so
this is similar to the online prediction
model that Adam talked about yesterday
we're now instead of now in each time
step the algorithm has to produce a
k-dimensional prediction nature or an
adversary produces a vector X T and you
get a payoff which is how much variance
of X did you capture and you measure
your regret as what you capture - what
the best K dimensional subspace could
have captured in hindsight this model
was studied by Varma then Guzman
Mahankali and warmoth and by Nick
applause Guillermo
and they've shown various results in
this setting now what we do know is that
if you have a stable algorithm which has
higher utility then you can convert that
to a low-rent algorithm this is what
Adam talked about yesterday and it turns
out that this noise addition gives me
sufficient stability to actually just
make that analysis go through so what we
get is a follow the perturb leader type
algorithm with expected read rate is
about square root K opt times n to the
1/4 so terms of this is n to the 1/4
away from the best-known
best-known algorithm for online
prediction due to one more thing Koosman
but Charlie Hasan and Hasan Colin one
was actually left open a question of
designing of FPL type algorithm which
has good regret guarantees they had
their guarantees were much worse than
this and this actually answers an open
question of theirs even if I didn't care
about privacy and in fact because we
actually had noise we actually get
privacy more or less for free
so unless hop is really tiny we get the
same regret without dependence on
Epsilon and in fact if you actually want
privacy this n to the 1/4 is necessary
you can't get a square root K time soft
and gentle ok so let me just mention the
lower bounds yeah so they had proposed
an F PL type algorithm to solve this
problem and then found a bug in it and
realized that it was wrong then they got
something that had worse so I guess the
main point is the one of course mean
that algorithm is computationally very
inefficient and since so in the online
prediction community they believe it's
nicer to have FPL type algorithm and
they are kind of left this open question
is there an F PL type algorithm for this
problem bit better regret guarantees and
this this improves upon the best known
FBI so so we have the square root K
times n in the that comes from the
amount of noise we add it's really a
square root K and times whatever the
variance of my noise is usually when
you're trying to convert when you're
trying to do follow the perturb leader
type algorithm you add noise which is
actually fairly large which is something
like square root of fault or you pick
the noise so as to optimize the error
you get from the noise plus another term
that shows up and when you optimize that
essentially the square then becomes an N
to the one foot yes that's the short
answer but the lower bound actually uses
techniques developed by Bannerman and
Adam based on previous work on getting
differential privacy door bounds from
data tracing schemes and turns out for K
equals 1 such a lower bound follows with
not too much difficulty for larger K
it's kind of somewhat challenging and
there's we need to use this somewhat
counterintuitive phenomenal that we call
the list culling game I can tell you
about it later
but yeah I guess I'm going to run out of
time so yeah so I guess essentially we
can get essentially exactly the schedule
and dependence for any K up to
essentially n so two logarithmic factors
all those gap independence is also tied
in fact yeah so that's all I'm gonna say
so basically we gave a very simple noise
addition mechanism which gives excellent
utility which actually gets better when
you do have an eigenvalue gap it also
gives me algorithms for online pca and
we can prove lower bounds for
differentially private algorithm that
match or no match or upper box
so in some sense at least in this model
we completely understand differentially
private PC I'll stop here yeah yeah we
have
yeah so then normalize their own but
then they think there is some parameter
bounced by the standard deviation of the
Gaussian so they do implement this
algorithm as they just add Gaussian
Gaussian noise matrix to the covariance
matrix and they plot their in terms of
the standard deviation
so then sub set includes this algorithm
adjust the NL Center or the analysis
that they had in mind was different so
you just need to change the scale on
there to say look at their plots and
just change their yeah I'm kidding
yes I guess we don't want to do the
another do the experiments we just
haven't gotten wrong
I think maybe I would like to remind you
sir I think this is the natural
logarithms forum at CCA it's just that
what you guys show is that you can
report dramatically better or epsilon
Delta values than we thought before but
I mean this is what you do you you you
add two Gaussian noise to the covariance
matrix right that's what everybody's
always been doing but now you can work
more to dramatically better epsilon
Delta values and that's the point of
this analysis so in some sense the
algorithm is the yeah it's just you get
much you get a much better you can label
X X is much better than they could
that's a different answer to this
question
and this would be a great algorithm to
use concentrated differential privacy
and drop the log one over Delta terms
alright if there are no further
questions first of all thank you